if you want to learn and change your
brain as an adult there has to be a high
level of focus and engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
you need to do is you need to regardless
of how agitated you feel you have to
lean in
and focus extremely hard neuroplasticity
is triggered when urgency and focus
combine you can sit there and just ramp
up your level of urgency through purely
psychological means those who will be
successful young or old
are going to be those people who can
create their own
internal buffers they're going to be
able to control their relationship to
pleasures because the proximity to
pleasures and the availability is the
problem neural plasticity which is this
incredible feature of our nervous
systems that allows it to change in
response to experience
neuroplasticity is arguably one of the
most important aspects of our biology it
holds the promise for each and all of us
to think differently to learn new things
to forget painful experiences and to
essentially adapt to anything that life
brings us by becoming better
i'm referring to the same process which
is the brain and nervous system's
ability to change itself there are a lot
of reasons why the nervous system would
do this it could do it in response to
some traumatic event it could for
instance create a sense of fear around a
particular place or a fear of
automobiles or planes it could also
occur when something positive happens
like the birth of our first child or
when our puppy does something amusing or
we see an incredible feat of performance
in athleticism all of us were born with
a nervous system that isn't just capable
of change but was designed to change
when we enter the world our nervous
system is primed for learning you can't
just decide to change your brain you
actually have to go through a series of
steps to change your internal state in
ways that will allow you to change your
brain one of the biggest lies in the
universe
that seems quite prominent right now is
that every experience you have
changes your brain people love to say
this they love to say your brain is
going to be different after this lecture
or your brain is going to be different
after today's class than it was two days
ago and that's absolutely not true the
nervous system doesn't just change
because you experience something unless
you're a very young child you hear so
often which is every experience that you
have is going to change the way your
brain works absolutely not
if you're a child
the things you hear and see and do are
shaping you right kids come home saying
things they've never even heard before
it's amazing
and as an adult you have to crack into
that neural circuitry and reshape it the
key thing is to identify not just one
but probably a kit of reasons several
reasons as to why you would want to make
this particular change
motivation
and the chemistry of motivation is
tightly wound in with the neurochemistry
of movement how do you get motivated
well one way to do that is if you are
good at subjectively attaching
dopamine to the pursuit just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier our
species arrived here because of this
dance between
arousal and relaxation arousal and
relaxation and one thing we can say for
sure about every human being that's
alive now is that their parents at least
once mastered this dance of relaxed but
not and excited but not too excited then
really excited and then relaxed that
dance was mastered by all of our parents
and that's what delivered us here to
some extent pursuing goals have this
balance is almost like a like a seesaw
there's activation and calm activation
and calm and it's that dynamic process
that's important to master in every
endeavor one of the most powerful things
that any person can do is to learn to
control
this idea of duration path and outcome
and attach an internal sense of reward
just that you're doing well to reward
yourself mentally just say i'm doing
well i'm actually on the right path the
more often that we can self-reward
some aspect of the process provided it's
in the right direction of what we're
trying to achieve the more energy we're
going to have for that the more focus
we're going to have for that and so when
people start realizing that if they set
the goals inside of the larger goal and
self-reward each one of those they
essentially have an infinite amount of
energy to pursue those goals they have
an infinite amount of focus to pursue
those goals so the keys are
to pursue rewards but understand that
the pursuit is actually the reward if
you want to have repeated
wins the celebration has to be less than
the pursuit and that's hard for some
people to do if we were to look at
ourselves through the lens of an
experiment like we would an animal
experiment we think that animal is sick
if you saw an animal digging in the
corner looking looking looking looking
for a bone the dog is looking looking
looking looking looking looking looking
looking you'd think that's really sad
that's us
one of the problems is we tend to fill
our idle time with more sensory
information and that doesn't allow us to
go into this deliberate decompression
very quickly and so the dopamine system
is just a little bit overwhelmed i don't
think we need to be off our phones all
the time we just take some time to just
deliberately decompress each day any
time of day
and you'll focus better this is
something that could be done for you
know five minutes a day of just turning
off or flipping over the phone and
thinking about something in it in a very
directed way and just watching how that
makes you feel if it makes you feel
agitated if it makes you feel good if it
makes you feel
a sense of desire those are
those actually would be a powerful
practices because it would give you a
window into
what's happening neurochemically when
you're scrolling on social media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
behavior and then you find that you're
scrolling like why am i doing this this
isn't that interesting that is this
isn't that interesting now
the algorithms for social media are very
clever and i don't want to demonize it
the algorithms that they've incorporated
function on the most powerful
way to keep people doing a behavior or
an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scoring and then
you see something
and then you what happens is you start
getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling it actually can be quite useful
to take some time and space away from
social media certainly from any
addictive drugs that's the treatment for
addiction and restore those dopamine
levels to baseline you've all heard of
this molecule dopamine that gives us
this sense of reward when we accomplish
something well if you get so much
dopamine from the reward of people
saying oh yeah you're absolutely going
to be able to do that you might not
actually go after the reward of the
accomplishment itself so beware these
positive reinforcements also
so i suggest that everyone ask
themselves what is it that i want to
accomplish and what is it that's driving
me to accomplish this and come up with
two or three things the molecule
dopamine is a really misunderstood
molecule dopamine is responsible for
that feeling of feeling great but in
addition
dopamine is what's released any time an
animal or human thinks it's on the right
path
and that's very subjective if you finish
a marathon in first place no one comes
along and drips dopamine in your ear you
self-generate that it's all internal
it's all about your internal
representation the problem is not
pleasures
the problem is that pleasure experienced
without prior requirement for pursuit is
terrible for us it's terrible for us as
individuals it's terrible for us as as
groups the internet gives you a dopamine
what we didn't realize is that repeated
engagement with these things leads to
dopamine depletion
and that the pain and pleasure balance
is always at work
we all should guard our dopamine peaks
very carefully a little bit goes a long
way a lot goes even further but it also
takes you down deeper afterwards this is
the basis of addiction so for every bit
of pleasure that we get from pursuit and
getting the thing that we were pursuing
the crash that comes afterwards feels
painful and
all that we need to do in order to
return to a baseline of dopamine renew
that resource little by little and by
rewarding each thing if you get up and
you
make bed you're not back on your heels
you make a cup of coffee you sit down
you script out something in a journal
you exercise
maybe you call a relative that you think
might need to hear from you or that
you'd like to talk to you do something
in a deliberate way just being
deliberate and learning to push away the
things that are trying to make you
reflexive is so important my goal is to
be as
you know deliberate and non-reflexive as
possible in life that's my goal from
when i wake up in the morning until i go
to sleep
my mind actually is not my best friend
at these extremes so
that's why i say if you can't control
the mind with the mind
look to the body to control the mind a
simple rule that people can adopt is
when your mind is not where you want it
to be
look to your body
use the body to shift the mind
it's a simple
equation if you do that you'll shift
the chemicals that are released in your
brain in a way that will allow you to
regain control of the steering wheel i
think we can all appreciate the value of
having habits habits organize our
behavior into more or less reflexive
action so we don't have to think too
much about performing the various
behaviors but of course there are many
habits that don't serve us well or that
perhaps even undermine our immediate and
long-term health goals and psychological
goals and even some habits that can
really undermine our overall life goals
first of all is this notion of immediate
goal-based habits versus identity-based
habits
immediate goal-based habits are going to
be habits that are designed to bring you
a specific outcome
as you do them so each and every time
you do them so for instance it might be
that you want to develop a habit of
getting
you know 60 minutes of zone 2 cardio
each day
or perhaps you know three four times a
week as we head into the new year that
would be an immediate goal-based habit
if your goal is to
get that cardio maybe four times a week
every time you do it you could check off
a little box and you'd say okay i did it
you met the goal that is different than
so-called identity-based habits where
there's a larger overarching theme to
the habit where you're trying to become
quote-unquote a fit person or you're
somebody who wants to be
an athlete or something of that sort
it's where you start to attach some sort
of larger picture about yourself or what
it means for you to do that habit where
there's both the immediate goal right
complete the exercise complete the
session or whatever it is
check off that box but that you're
linking it to some sort of larger gold
the goal of any habit that we want to
form is to get into what's called
automaticity automaticity is fancy
language for the neural circuits can
perform it automatically and that's the
ultimate place to be
right if you have all these goals and
things that you want to be doing on a
regular basis you'd love for them to be
habitual because it takes less mental
and physical effort less limbic friction
in order to execute those if you're
having trouble focusing chances are
you're focusing too much
it's like an appetite if you're just
snacking all the time it's just the meal
doesn't taste quite as good any form of
turning the brain conscious thought
deliberate thought off will allow you to
do incredibly deep work after that but
the mistake is just constantly digesting
information how do you increase focus
you know people are so familiar with
sitting down reading a couple pages of a
book and realizing that none of it sunk
in or talking to someone and seeing
their mouth move maybe even nodding your
head subconsciously and
none of it sinks in this can be very
damaging for school work performance and
relationships as many of you know
the best way
to get better at focusing
is to use the mechanisms of focus that
you were born with and the key principle
here is that mental focus
follows visual focus you can use your
visual focus
and you can increase your visual focus
as a way of increasing your mental of
focus abilities more broadly when you
are excited about something or you
really want to attend to something it
literally brings about a narrowing of
the aperture of your visual window and
your auditory window so that you attend
to this particular location in space oh
of course mental focus follows visual
focus and yet if you think about the way
our world is arranged now with you know
your phone calling you over to this
location and your computer calling you
to that location and whatever's
happening in your immediate environment
calling to that location and things that
are happening within your body it makes
perfect sense we now know with certainty
that a regular gratitude practice can
shift the pro-social circuit so that
they dominate our physiology and our
mindset in ways that can enhance many
many aspects of our physical and mental
health by default so we don't always
have to constantly be in practice trying
to be happy gratitude practices provided
they are the effective ones and they are
performed regularly
can shift those circuits such that we
are happier on average even when we are
not performing those practices the fact
that being grateful for something
external to the event
happens to release serotonin and have a
certain soothing effect or
dopamine and give you more epinephrine
and let you go further that's not a hack
that's actually what allowed the human
machine to evolve to the point that it
is now so
being able to access the genuine
internal states of gratitude and reward
works you can't trick the system you
can't pretend that you're grateful for
something but if you can identify or
attach yourself to some larger goal or
something that's deeply gratifying to
you that's not a hack
that's accessing the deepest components
of your nervous system